all trumps former campaign chairman
who's already been indicted in the whole
Russia collusion probe may now face a
tougher sentence Paul Manafort is
accused of lying to the FBI something he
denies he believes he has provided
truthful information and does not agree
with the government's characterization
or that he has breached the agreement
however lying accusation appears in a
report by Special Counsel Robert
Mueller's office which claims manifold
reached a plea deal however it doesn't
specify what he lied about or when
though this has not stopped the media
from laying into him today was the
deadline for the Moller team to tell the
judge whether manna Ford is telling them
the whole truth and tonight they say no
not even close former Trump campaign
chairman manna Ford lied to the FBI and
to the special counsel in a breach of
his plea agreement after he pleaded
guilty and agreed to cooperate with
prosecutors
so after he'd reached this whole deal he
lies to Bob Miller's team he lies to the
FBI legal analyst Jennifer Breeden told
us that manifold must be provided with
more details to be able to defend
himself when it comes to media stories
and what the US mainstream media is
choosing to is choosing to play on this
narrative is specifically surrounding
the man of Ford allegations and Manta
for trials and the Mueller
investigations it's always a narrative
that they're trying to play they're
trying to show it is very confusing as
to why none of the media stories that
have come out had provided substance now
in the articles that shows that mana
Ford's defense attorneys had already
responded to some of these allegations
from the federal prosecutors stating
that he lied yet none of the media
stories seemed to state that which means
either that none of the details have
been raised or that federal prosecutors
didn't provide mana Ford or his
attorneys with the specifics on how he
lied they're saying that he lied to
federal prosecutors which is part of the
plea deal which would now result in more
federal charges but in the u.s. we have
the Fifth Amendment of the Constitution
states that you're guaranteed due
process if they're talking about new
federal charges being brought because of
Lies or omissions the accused is is
afforded under US law to know what the
charges are against
tenly specifics of that so that they can
defend themselves
you